they're gonna be facing the right-hander
casey mize he's making his fourth start
first start against the royals so it'll
be interesting he's got a bunch of guys
that he's never faced and we're gonna
see how he fares but strike one always
the name of the game for everyone the
two two pitch swinging to miss oh
there's a good cutter
down and away and perez just waved at a
gym that's one of the
we've seen some good ones but that was
one of the best we've seen him throw
absolutely perfect late movement to it
and there's a lot of right-hand batters
in there for mike miner and sometimes
that's playing to his strength that's
right mike miner knows how to get out
career batting average 245 versus
right-handers which is really good
breaking ball is cut on and missed
and that's miners first strikeout ryan
o'hearn back with the big league ball
club he's been at our alternate site
called up today
nice high way to go seeing some plate
seeing some pitches there in his first
play to paris the 1-0
grounded sharply to third could be two
to short the tournament is in time
to get dozier
that was quick
the transfer from
short from glove to hand is beautiful
isn't it
ben attendee
[Music]
his first home run as a royal goes to
the opposite field
and he just missed a home run on
wednesday night to the opposite field
against the rays oh man he's oh
he's so deserving of that you know he's
coming on we saw it in the series he got
it welcome to the royals he ran badu
into the fence
here's the pitch he did challenge him
and struck him out with a good hard
slider down and in
on the right-handed hitter
second strikeout for minor and that's
after falling behind 3-0 pitch by minor
is swung on hit well left center field
racing over ben intended he dies and
makes a terrific catch
wow what a start for ben and tendy a
home run and now he takes extra bases
away from wilson ramos
mike miner with the biggest smile right
now in the field as he tipped his cap to
ben attendee
that was as good a play as you'll see
any left fielder make and he's a
left-handed thrower so that's the
backhand side as he's diving to his left
mike
kicks in deals
and he went around on that slider down
and away a strikeout that's the third
strikeout
as the batter badou tried to hold up
with his swing but
the home plate umpire tonight is ben may
and he says that was a swing
out over the plate and salvi off of his
knuckles drops it into center field
that's the royal second hit
and that brings up solaire
but when you throw it about belt high
those could be a double play here though
jack zach short turns it quickly and
that one was easy
nice start by good room nice finish by
zach short there's two away in the
fourth
you know pitcher's best friend and these
are huge huge outs you see that ball hit
off the heel of nico he does a nice job
keeping his hands and then zach short
almost like he's done this a million
times casey mize back to work and the
pitch to o'haran is hit well deep right
that is gone just over the wall in right
field ryan o'hearn in his first game of
the year already a walk and a home run
and we're only in the fourth inning
royals lead it two nothing so ryan
o'hearn making loud noises in his
debut for this season not wasting any
time as he
hit that one to the shortest part of the
ballpark right over the fence but
pitch was up a little bit he got the
head of the bat on it fizz
and just enough to get it out of here
there goes good room they got him picked
off santana's throw is a little high
and he's in there safely just a huge
jump but it took miner a little while to
get the ball over to santana
and then the throw that's up see how
merrifield had a jump for it
nico i think gets well in between there
though he comes off the bag
see this pop-up slide there's time right
there but he's got the tag applied so
if they challenge it which i don't think
they're going to challenge that's good
goodrum takes off for third and he will
be out foolish thank you yeah
you know salvi is a master at picking
the ball up off the ground okay that
ball better kick 10 15 feet away because
he is so quick that's why he never
catches him look at him he says great
he's going look at that throw wasn't
even where it wanted where he wanted it
but had plenty of quickness and snap
throws kane was third one year okay my
bad there's a call that goes miners way
and he has struck out his fourth zac
short you know he's looking for a
batting average his parents are here and
everything but it's not gonna happen
right there
fastball right by him
take a little pressure off of him
and it's working and back to the middle
and into center and ben attendee
is two for two he's had a
a good week as far as hard hit balls go
yes you can tell he's coming
grounded through the right side with ben
and tendy running so he will go to third
and that was not a hit-and-run jump he
was running to steal and
taylor took advantage of that wide open
right side
taylor runs and it's grounded to the
right side
scope has to scramble back to first
ben and tendy scores the royals lead
three nothing and they have taylor at
second base mize to the plate and whit
swings and drops it into right field for
a hit taylor will round third and he'll
come in and score and the royals lead it
four nothing
boy that's a good piece of hitting by
whitmer field but also a great read by
taylor he knew that ball was going to
drop and vance wilson did too and vance
immediately waved him home
so that is rbi number 13 for wood
merrifield he has his first hit of the
night trust the guy behind you and the
guy behind him right now is jorge
solaire
solaire rips it up the left field line
and that's down into the corner
wit scores santana is going to be waved
home
and no relay jorge solaire
hits a two out two run double
the royals have four in the fifth inning
and they lead six nothing nice
just how to start the road trip
confidence there's not an easy out in
the lineup solaire you get him going you
get ben and tendy going salvi's already
gone look at how they pull for each
other thanks for picking me up yeah well
they got to get this offense going
here's the 3-2
a rope to left
that's a good looking sign right there
as candelario digs for two
he will cruise in with a leadoff double
here in the fifth the tigers first hit
of the night
oh grossman turns on one
tigers are on the board thanks to the
two-run jack
from robbie grossman
well very
very rewarding for robbie grossman who
has been fighting it himself lately
he jumps on a little bit of a hanging
breaking ball and he doesn't miss it
see that ball left over the middle it's
another curveball slider
robbie just
spun the field on it and he barreled it
didn't he simo
and a breaking ball got him looking so
minor
responds after the home run and gets his
sixth strikeout
breaking ball got him looking
goodrum is down on strikes and that's
number eight for minor tonight wow great
spot with his curve that knuckle curve
is absolutely working that brings up
zach short here's the 3-2 there's a base
hit to left keep that baseball after an
eight pitch at bat zach short arrives in
the majors with his first big league
knock good for him
carlos santana giving him a pat on the
chest same way to go
and there it is they're going to keep it
hanging slider actually wasn't all that
bad he went down got it down and away a
little bit pulled it into left field
clean solid hit no doubter good for him
okay mom you can relax now oh man one
and two the count runner at first one
out miner checks the runner now the
pitch and a swing and a miss at a
breaking ball down making nine
strikeouts for mike miner tonight
[Applause]
right down the middle at 100 miles an
hour and the royals
take game one
of the four-game series in detroit and
game one of the nine-game road trip
outstanding work ben attendee way to
check in in the home run department